hi i'm chris evans i'm anna de armas and
i'm reggie john page and we are the cast
of the great and we're here to see that
we can survive a top-secret mission
buzzfeed
first pick a top secret code name all
right so the options are firebird 22
crystal skull and moonlight i was going
to choose fireball no that's mine oh
that's yours okay you can have
firebrushes i'm taking them
you're taking normally i'm taking
moonlight okay and then i guess i'm
going crystal skull
i had heard rooms
just saying which iconic netflix tv
character is joining your team hey
sharma from bridgeton eddie munson from
stranger things joe goldberg from you
and victor hargreaves from umbrella
academy oh
it's pretty your turn you must i don't
know okay let's take a look all right
i'm taking cake you're taking shape yeah
any moments i'm from stranger things see
i i don't know these shows i mean eddie
looks like a fun dude and he's an
awesome man maybe i'll take eddie he
looks like he has a good time eddie has
fought off the hordes of hell with
metallica guitar oh look at him and then
the no brainer i guess i'm going eddie i
think so too yeah i'm sorry oh wait
should i be selecting these things i'm
not even clicking on mine
choose a pump up song to get you ready
for the mission okay we have don't stop
me now by queen we got bad guy by billy
eilish i have the tiger by survivor and
run the world by beyonce
i mean i'm going i have to go
no you go i was going to go i had a
tiger don't stop me now i'll stop right
now
unstoppable
chris needs those steps he wants to do a
little dance that's right some
bystanders are getting a little
suspicious how comfortable are you with
lying
i'm the world's worst liar i tell a
little fib every now and then i don't
love to lie but i'll do it if i have to
joke's on you nobody even knows my real
name um i i'm gonna say are we lying now
oh look at you like always getting real
meta i i was gonna say i don't love to
lie but but i'll do it if i have to
that's really you i mean i was gonna say
i'm the world's worst liar which i
really am not a great liar but i'll do
it if i have to i'm gonna say i'll take
home nobody even knows my real name i'm
clearly am firebird so
nobody knows who that is i tell a little
fib every now and then there you go just
you know just to keep keep the world
spicy it almost seems dignified yeah
when you say it i mean carmichael's a
good feather that's that's what he does
all day long just little flips yes
sprinklers sprinkles in on it
okay it's game time you have four
possible routes to get eyes on your
target how do you proceed
i'll take the fastest route through the
dark terrifying tunnel i'll take the the
rooftop route i'm not afraid of heights
i'm actually already inside
[Music]
i think i know what my option is i'll
walk in the front door hiding in plain
sight is my specialty i'm on i'm already
inside your audience
i'm gonna walk in front in front of
everyone through the door yeah uh and
i'll say i'll i'll take the fastest
route through the dark terrifying time
hold up your location has been
compromised and the enemy is heading
straight towards you what is your next
move we have turned the opposite
direction and run find a loose ceiling
tile and escape through the air ducts
jump through the nearest window i'll
worry about injuries later stick it out
and fire them head on
[Music]
i'm finding a loose ceiling tile like
y'all can do the throwing yourselves out
of windows stuff just thinking about too
i'm gonna stick it out and fight him
head on i was just gonna say that i'm
gonna go with
five them uh you finally reached your
target what's your last step wait for
backup to arrive before making any
contact trick that's trusting me only to
attack later let my conscience get the
best of me
and abort the mission entirely
take matters into my own hands and fight
them face to face i have no conscience i
mean i have to fight them already i mean
i have to i just walk through the door
in plain sight right i'll fight them
[Music]
i survived you made it
you just that was the reveal all right
so then i'll say i'll say wait no i mean
i don't know i just got confetti all
over so i got very excited i feel like i
need to in honor of carmichael inside
the elegant option again i'm going to
trick them and then fight them later
you're going to trigger them okay so
then i won't take that one either wait
which one did you take anna you you took
matters into your own hands
all right this is your mission okay i
let my conscience get the best of me and
i bought the admission no
you know what i mean oh but i survived
anyway all right all right let's see if
tricking them works i bet i'm the only
one who dies oh we also oh we all
survived
we all made it i survived but i got
captured by the enemy disappointed oh is
that what he says no no i didn't like
we got distracted by the confetti i
survived but got captured right well it
looks like you got caught definitely not
an ideal outcome but hey at least you
survived and we'll have a good story to
tell don't be too hard on yourself it
happens to even the best despise better
luck next i got a consolation prize this
is a participation prize of the spy
world this is outrageous what'd you get
anna i'm a true professional your super
spy skills just keep getting better and
better she's not really reading that
that's not what it says you're the most
talented likable
good looking person mine says uh you
survived congrats things were a little
touch and go for a minute but you made
it through victoria so you're a true
professional and you're super spicy i
just i just read the best part oh okay
yeah
there it is okay but it looks like we
all made it mostly i'm tied up in a
corner be sure to watch gray man on
netflix
[Music]